le test est prêt rachel a écrit une
lettre à ross et a exigé qu'il la lise avant
qu'ils ne se remettent ensemble combien de
pages cette lettre 18 pages 18 pages recto
et verso recto et verso est correct attendez
attendez
oh mon
dieu on y va
où est la boîte de mouchoirs
[  Musique]
le coût des amis
wow
est-ce que courtney a encore ses répliques
écrites sur la table
[Musique]
nous venons littéralement de revenir
[Applaudissements]
nous regrettons d'
avoir un tel lien de ce spectacle étaient
ross et rachel en pause oui oui
oui oui des conneries
[Applaudissements]
le premier tableau lu c'est la première
fois que je pose les yeux sur l'un de vous, tout le monde
était si parfaitement casté
ouais c'est de celui où tout le monde le
découvre
[Rires]
je me souviens que je suis allé voir le producteur de l'
émission je  était allumé et il a dit que l'émission
ne ferait pas de toi une star
Je me souviens d'une fois où je devais avoir les
nouvelles et à la télé il y avait une vue aérienne
de chacune de nos maisons oh bon sang je me souviens de l'avoir
regardé faire ce que
mon toit
c'était un moment incroyable
w  ho est devenu meilleur ami
ouais je vais pleurer maintenant
quand je regarde les épisodes je
ris à haute voix parce que vous me faites tous rire
si fort
je sais que vous savez à quel point le spectacle est grand ce que
vous avez donné à tant de gens est une
expérience  d'un immense confort oh mon dieu
nous avions l'impression d'avoir ces amis je
vous aime tellement vous